[Music]
[Applause]
Conan O'Brien here this is my video blog
I'm super excited it's the first episode
of the second season I'm really glad
that I've renewed myself here's and you
say what's going on in my world I'm so
excited to go see the new Twilight movie
I can't believe it's finally here I've
been practicing all my twilight phases
so here's a segment I called Twilight
faces smiley faces here's the face I'm
gonna make when the Wolfpack decides to
kill Bella's vampire baby here's the
face I'm gonna make the first time Jacob
takes off his shirt there's the face I'm
gonna make the fourth time Jacob takes
off you sure yeah all right this is a
new segment called obvious spoilers via
spoilers this is where I spoiled their
ending to movies and TV shows that you
probably could have figured out anyway
first up is the movie J Edgar spoiler
alert he gets old and dies next up is
the TV show Cake Boss
spoiler alert at the end of the show the
Cake Boss he makes a pretty good cake
and people enjoy it
sorry last a very Harold & Kumar
Christmas spoiler alert
at the end they probably get Santa hi
obvious Tyler's here's a segment called
tony's on ponies Tony's on ponies this
is where I take pictures of famous
people named Tony and I put them on top
of cute ponies here's Tony Bennett on a
pony
hey here's Tony Soprano an opponent it's
kind of depressed
here's 80s R&B group Tony Tony Tony all
on a pony Tony's on ponies Tony's on
ponies ok this next segment is called
animals that just found out that Kim
Kardashian's marriage only lasted 72
days first up he's a sheep she just she
can't freakin believe it
check out this dog
and this cat really can't believe it I
have to admit that was a pretty awesome
segment hey Andy get in here Andy what
that segment deserved a high five all
right yeah in fact I think it deserves
infinite high-fives check this out
engage infinite high-five
[Applause]
we'll take a break when we come back
Kristen Stewart's here we'll see you in
a second